we can ask him about the early draw
thank you for joining us Andrew
Christian Andrew tell us a bit about uh
this decision to uh score an early draw
it hasn't been your event up to this
point but again with the white pieces
you somehow want to fight at all times
tell us a bit about this
decision yeah um well I did feel quite
bad after yesterday's game because I
kind of just beat myself I think um and
I mean I was ready to fight but I
expected him to take more risks so I
honestly didn't really expect this line
I
thought um after I played Knight B5
Knight C3 that at least he would try to
Castle or something MH so I didn't
really prep the main lines with H4 I was
prepping mainly for other stuff
and um yeah I mean I feel a bit bad
about doing this to him but I really
expected him to take more risks somehow
so yeah I mean after he he repeat did I
I I didn't feel comfortable playing H4
yep so you wanted to play this card of
being the low rated player and trying to
Blackmail your opponent with this draw
situation and then he took it uh tell us
a bit about your story uh at the US Open
you won that tournament tell us a bit
about that because I do remember in the
last round there were a lot of players
tied for that top position and then you
emerged Victorious that qualified you to
the US Championship tell us a bit about
that
yeah I remember going into the last
round I was actually I was quite unhappy
because the pairings were pretty bad for
me I was playing akobian with black our
good friends remember here with us yes
yeah Brodsky was like playing down and
there was also Jason leang playing White
against somebody else so there was a
bunch of us who could have uh been in
contention for for winning but at some
point it looked like Brodsky was like
completely winning so so both of us knew
that we had to take risks and maybe I
was very slightly better but the
position was quite equal but like uh
yeah we both decided we need to take
some risks and the position just ended
up going my way I was just patient and
yeah took my chances uh it was probably
the biggest win of my career I guess
absolutely that was uh a big tournament
victory for you and you are a full-time
employee of Sig uh and you took some
time off from your day job tell us B
about that was your company supporting
this uh us Championship participation
for you yeah for sure I mean Sig has
like a huge gaming culture like I think
they're even a sponsor of chess.com so
they're definitely uh you know like
pretty happy to help me out here because
it's like my I've just started working
for a month so normally they don't
really want new employees to take so
much vacation time
like during the beginning training
stages and also I just didn't have
enough vacation cuz it's not even my
first full year so they helped me out by
uh helping me out with the vacation days
and yeah I'm I'm very thankful for them
because this is like a once in
a-lifetime opportunity for me so it's
definely it was very nice of them and I
know Sig is also a partner of the
collegio chess league so I'm dealing
with their company as well they
definitely love chess players thank you
very much for joining us and good luck
tomorrow thank you thank you indeed
Andrew as round three is underway Kate
where were